what's up guys i've got a sick chest
composition i came across last night i
want to share with you guys white is up
three pieces and it looks like they're
totally winning but it's black to move
black started with d2 and it looks like
this pawn is impossible to stop so if
you want to try to solve this study
pause the video right now try some
different things and see if you can find
the correct solution all right now i'm
going to go through the solution go
through my thoughts i was unable to get
this study i came across it in the
chess.com tactics trainer and the first
thing i noticed is that this king is
really weak so even though there might
not be a way to stop the pawn we might
be able to make some mating net i also
toyed with the idea that maybe we can
set up a fortress with pawn going on a4
and then bishop oscillating between d4
and e3
and you know maybe this is a fortress
since all of the pieces are defended but
the problem is once black promotes
they can actually just push d4 and we
don't have enough defenders on that
square and that just breaks the fortress
down so unfortunately that's not going
to work when i was initially looking at
the study i did not see a fast enough
way to put black in a mating net before
their queen could wreak havoc on white's
pieces but you have to see the exact way
to get black into a checkmate starting
with bishop f3 and this is a very
important move and we might see why a
little bit later but of course we're
covering the d1 square so black must
take this and now it's important to keep
the king in a mating net keep the king
in a box if the king gets out then we're
totally screwed because once again we
can't stop this pawn the question is do
we play king c7 or king c8 the answer is
you gotta play king c8 here because we
want the c7 square for our knight in a
couple moves so we play king c8 and we
can allow black to promote d1 equals
queen and now it looks crazy because
black is up a queen for two minor pieces
but the really cool thing about mating
nets is once you're in a mating net you
just can't get out and it doesn't matter
how much material you're up or down
you're gonna get checkmated if you're in
a mating net so we can actually play
knight e6 here and the mating net is
knight c7 and bishop d4 and
black has to sacrifice the queen to get
out the best black has is queen c2
knight c7 check king a7 and this is
actually going to end up in checkmate
anyway because black only has one move
and we just take this and it's going to
be checkmate so we trap the king on the
corner and that is how you solve this
but
what if black doesn't play
these moves there are a couple other
options black has what if black here
goes with king a7 well same thing we
just continue setting up our mating net
we just played bishop d4 now of course
if the king continues to escape we can
actually play knight b3 check and pick
up the pawn so of course black tries to
promote here but we just go 96 check and
black can either sacrifice the queen and
it'll be a winning endgame for white or
if they play king a6 or king a8 we can
now play knight c7 and this is still
going to be
checkmate uh this is actually this is
actually
what we call a perfect mate which is
when every square is covered exactly one
time and they're really beautiful and
aesthetically pleasing and we can see
you can see here the bishop covers these
two squares the knight covers these two
squares the king covers this square and
the pawn covers this square and every
square is covered exactly once now the
last mystery of this study is why can't
we just go for this mating net straight
away why do we have to throw in bishop
f3 why can't we just go king c8 knight
bringing to c7 and bishop d4 straight
away well let's see what happens if that
happens black starts with d2 we bring
the king in king to c8 and now if black
promotes well now while we playing
knight e6 black doesn't have to go queen
c2 the threat is obviously
bishop d4 knight c7 which is either
going to be checkmate or win the queen
black here can actually play queen g4
pinning the knight so knight c7 is no
longer possible and black is actually
going to win this because white doesn't
have this knight c7 move so that's the
reason we need to start with bishop f3
so this pawn blocks the diagonal there's
no pin on g4 hope you guys enjoyed that
study a little bit of a shorter one
today but i enjoyed it a lot so i hope
you guys did as well make sure to like
and subscribe thank you guys for
watching i'll see you next time